it has been one month to the day since
Channing Tatum and Jenna Dewan announced
their shocking split after being married
for eight years now both are apparently
moving on in Michelle Turner checked in
on the former mrs. Tatem you look good
how you doing you good I'm really good
thank you for happy thank you I
appreciate all the love thank you
Jenna's moving on but she isn't the only
one adjusting to her split from Channing
please welcome Jenna Dewan Tatum Jenna
and Jenna Dewan sorry Ellen apologized
to Jenna on her show today after
accidentally calling her by her former
last name I have to say before we go to
break I I'm so sorry I introduced you
and I it was just such a habit and I
have to say the way that you and
Channing are handling everything is
beautiful and for your daughter and I
apologize that I just have known both of
you for so long and I'm so used to
saying good now
thank you and I think I me honestly
thank you and everybody for all the love
Jenna got a big hug from her world of
Dan's co-star Jennifer Lopez the webcast
hit the red carpet last night at an Emmy
for your consideration event promoting
the show as for Gina's ex well Channing
is taking some time away from Hollywood
following the split on Monday the actor
shared this image of three guys in the
great outdoors with the simple caption
sanctuary Channing and Jenna are devoted
co-parents to their daughter Everly
Jenna told me the four-year-old has her
own moves in ballet class all the other
girls are you know doing their fifth
position and then Evy's over in the
corner and she's like like she's feeling
her own groove in her own beat and I was
like do you girl do you
you